and where do you think this comes from
Heaven because I'm quite persuaded by
the argument that and I don't hear many
people making this argument but I'm sort
of thinking about more and more that it
is the development of technology that
allows people to you know transition
more more effectively if you like and
and to pass more as other sector and so
on that sort of opened this up and
because of that we are now in the
position they're in there are other
people go well it's the academics in the
60s and where do you think this comes
from
I think like all really interesting and
strange phenomena it's a perfect storm
like a lot of things arrived at the same
point together
I think there probably have always been
people who have thought that they would
like to be the opposite sex or that they
were meant to be the opposite sex
and we used to know until we'd forgotten
like how that worked out like how that
happened
and so you know in the 70s and 80s there
were these prospective studies where
they identified little boys who said
ardently that they thought they were
meant to be little girls and they
followed them into adulthood and what
they were was gay
because there's a strong very strong
link between being really highly gender
and unconforming in childhood early
childhood and growing up to be gay
um so those kids they look around them
they don't they're not born thinking I
was meant to be a girl or I was meant to
be a boy they look around them and they
think why am I so different why are
people treating me like this you know
why do I not fit in why does my dad drag
me out to rugby matches and grab my
Barbie doll away from me or whatever you
know so those kids they learn from the
society that they're in that they should
have been the opposite sex there's
always been that
and so some of those kids just grow up
and they they work out they're gay and
that's fine I mean I should say it's not
all that they're gay but anyway it's
just like strong statistical link
um so there was always that and then
Along Came medical technology that
allowed you know some surgeries and so
on quite brutal surgeries and not
terribly effective still
but anyway those surgery started
then I do think the academics had
something to do with it
um you know there's this whole move you
know post-modernism what they call the
postmodern turn which is when you stop
thinking that words describe reality and
you start thinking words create reality
and the thing is both of those things
are true you know words do create
reality they start wars they you know
they make things happen but they also
describe reality I can't just say any
word means what I like and still live in
a world where you know trains run and
operations are successful and you know
that sort of thing
so is the postmodern terrain is like
moving away from the reality and towards
the words and then they just get like a
kind of intoxicated on it and unmoored
from anything and then Along Comes the
internet
and I would say that's the last of the
pieces I would pick out that
um you know in an internet World in an
online world you forget that you're
actually a physical being very easily
like you live through your avatar you
see people on screens you're not doing
manual labor
um you know we've delayed Char bearing
people have fewer children lots of
people have no children you just you
just can actually pretend much more
successfully that men and women are just
more similar than they are
so yeah I mean that's not all of it by
any means by the book if you want to
know the whole story but you know those
are the bits I'd pick out to get us
where we are where we say that there's
no difference between men and women or
that men and women are arbitrary
categories that we can redefine as we
wish but Helen there's also as well
several strands to this because uh the
people or normally men who transition
later on in life are very different like
we say to young boys who want to
transition but also the young girls who
will then want to transition to be boys
that's a completely different thing
entirely as well isn't it men and women
are different and their motivations for
wanting to be the opposite sex are very
different too
um and then sexualities are different
most people are straight a few people
are gay some people are you know on a
spectrum of bisexuality in between so
those people are going to have different
motivations as well and you see it's
funny how you see the differences
between men and women more clearly when
you look at men and women who don't want
to be men and women so I mean by and
large the women who transition
are a lesbian if they're adults or
they're teenage girls who are going
through adolescence and finding it tough
adolescence always is tough but for
girls you know there's a whole
you know it's earlier than it used to be
you may be 11 when men start gorping at
your tits and you know it's not very
pleasant and you think life would be
easier as a boy uh and then you look
online and you say why do I feel so
uncomfortable with my body why do I feel
uncomfortable being me and the answer
you'll get is trans
no that wasn't true 10 years ago 10
years ago you got better advice but now
the advice is if you think you may be
trans you probably are
so that's that bunch and then the little
boys uh yeah I mean they're very
effeminate little boys and there's still
a lot of homophobia out there you know
there really are people who look at
little boy in a dress who says that his
favorite toy is a Barbie doll and think
Hmm we'll see about that
and then the adult men I mean you know
the fact is probably three to five
percent of men are erotic cross-dressers
like we knew that you know those surveys
were done before this latest uh pretense
that men can be women they find this an
erotic idea to be a woman to to inhabit
the role of a woman
um you know you would have kept that at
the weekend and cross-dressing parties
maybe you know between you and your wife
20 years ago now you're stunning and
brave and that lady comes and you get
you know you get
societal claudits for what what is
actually just a neurotic interest so are
you saying that um that some men or a
lot of men who transition later on in
life it's an erotic thing for them it's
sort of fetish almost yeah
okay I mean you can see that if you look
if you if you actually look at the you
know the
the chat rooms and the Reddit the
subreddits and so on clearly it is I
mean they're not you know they're not
dressing in Dowdy women's clothes
they're not heading you know they're not
putting on T-shirt and jeans and heading
out to you know
pick up the shopping and the kid from
Nursery or something it's very it's very
very sexualized
it's all about heels and lipstick and
you know
yeah I mean it's it's just quite obvious
once you stop thinking that it's an
identity and start thinking like what's
your motivation here mate
[Music]